hola buenas noches así como lo menciona
este estado es tan importante que los
dos candidatos han decidido dejar sus
últimas visitas antes de las elecciones
para este estado importante porque
entrega 12 votos electorales es un
estado que tradicionalmente votaba azul
votada por el partido demócrata desde el
92 hasta 2012 pero en 2016 el tema del
desempleo fue uno de los aspectos
importantes la promesa del presidente
don aarón de crear más trabajos que
llevó a la victoria en este estado en
2016 de donaldson por un margen muy
pequeño y es que este estado es un área
es un estado industrial que tiene
dificultad todavía desempleo tiene una
gran población creciente latina y por
eso se convierte en un estado batalla
las últimas encuestas dan una mayoría a
bailén frente a la intención de voto
para la próxima semana tiene a cambiando
de tema se esperaba que los republicanos
en el senado confirmarán hoy lunes a la
candidata de donald trump para la corte
suprema hablamos de emi con ibar que se
sabe al respecto y cómo está el ambiente
hubo protestas
así de se han registrado protestas
frente a la casa blanca protestas frente
al congreso incluso a la corte suprema
por parte de organizaciones que
defienden los derechos civiles los
derechos reproductivos y consideran que
la jueza no árabe podría ser una de las
más conservadoras en llegar al tribunal
supremo los republicanos tienen los
votos para poder confirmarla esta misma
noche y de hecho el presidente de hunán
tram ya ha preparado una ceremonia de
juramentación a las nueve de la noche
tiempo de la costa este de los eeuu
desde la casa blanca para juramentar
oficialmente a barrett como el nuevo
miembro del tribunal supremo de los
estados unidos así que ella podría
llegar a tomar decisiones de ser
juramentada esta noche en las próximas
semanas incluso en la semana número la
segunda semana de noviembre cuando se
espera que el tribunal aborde un tema
tan importante como es el acceso a
cuidado en salud de manera se escribe
para los estadounidenses
diana castañeda muchísimas gracias por
este completísimo reporte desde
washington